from sleeper hits like it comes at night
to box office record breakers like it
and get out
2017 has been a great year for horror
but for every high-profile killer Klown
there are a dozen low-key horror movies
that slip straight onto DVD or more
frequently these days video on demand
here are the underappreciated horror
movies that you may have missed in 2017
the devil's candy mixing heavy metal and
horror The Devil's candy follows a
struggling artist played with an
unsettling creepiness by ethan embry who
moves his family out to rural Texas when
the previous owner of their new house
starts making sinister nights and visits
the family's already turbulent lifestyle
descends into horror The Devil's candy
made the rounds at horror festivals in
2015 but it wasn't until 2017 that the
film got a more widespread release via
video on-demand services written and
directed by Sean Byrne whose previous
film was the equally unique horror flick
called the loved ones
The Devil's candy plays with beams from
old school of cult films while
confidently slipping into its own modern
take on the genre just the Gus
[Applause]
the evil within it's impossible to talk
about the evil within without mentioning
writer-director and Righetti who spent
more than a decade meticulously crafting
this schizophrenic passion project
before passing away in 2015 two years
before the film was released but he left
us with a very well-made highly visual
horror movie that will surely leave
viewers with some very specific
nightmares
the evil would then tells the story of a
mentally handicapped man named Dennis
played by Fredrik Koehler who lives with
his brother played by Sean Patrick
Flanery after Dennis's reflection starts
telling him to kill people things go
downhill pretty quickly to put it mildly
yeah that's good waste in it again
Berlin Syndrome Stockholm Syndrome is a
disturbing condition in which someone
who's been kidnapped develops a sense of
affection for the kidnapper the film for
Lynde syndrome plays with that idea by
following an Australian tourist who has
a one-night stand with a man in Berlin
only to find herself locked in his
apartment the struggle that follows is
pure psychological horror that dives
deep into the mindset of survival and
the subtleties of psychosis all anchored
by a phenomenal performance by
Australian actress Teresa Palmer at a
phone pounding musical score sometimes
touching sometimes brutal for a Lynne
syndrome is definitely a trip abroad
that you won't forget anytime soon the
black coats daughter
writer-director aux perkins slow-burn
possession film the black coats daughter
was made in 2015 but didn't secure a
release until 2017
starring American horror stories Emma
Roberts and Dexter's James remar the
film centers on two girls who are left
at their prep school after the rest of
the kids go home for vacation it turns
out that both girls are hiding a secret
an events start to spiral out of their
control in the worst possible way if
you're looking for a Gore fest filled
with jump scares
you're better off looking elsewhere but
if you want to spend your night with an
atmospheric horror film that bleeds
tension cue this one up it's fun to be
scared sometimes a dark song you
couldn't ask for a more powerful
directorial debut than a dark song and
Liam Gavin who pulled double duty is
both writer and director on this smart
engaging portrayal of ritual black magic
it's definitely a director to look for
in the future
Gavin crafted a surreal minimalist film
that may be one of the most technically
detailed occult movies of the last
decade if not ever
there aren't any jump scares very little
blood but the build up over at dark
songs 100 minute timeline is just as
satisfying as the ultimate climax dig
two graves
not your typical horror movie dig two
graves is more of a hard-boiled revenge
tale the story centers on a young girl
who makes a pact with a group of gypsy
mountain men to bring her brother back
from the dead if she's willing to pay
the price this indie thriller premiered
at the New Orleans Film Festival in
October 2014 then quietly sat in the
shadows until it was released online in
2017 but it was certainly worth the wait
dig two graves Glen's revenge thriller
fantasy and horror themes into one
twisted tale of a girl who may have to
make the ultimate sacrifice for her
family lakebottom while it may look like
a run-of-the-mill Screamfest Lake
bottoms twist is selling itself as a
teen slasher flick when it manages to be
so much more if you've never heard of it
don't beat yourself up after a short
festival run this Finnish horror
released slept quietly on to shudder a
video-on-demand service specializing in
horror movies virtually ensuring that
only a handful of people outside of
Finland would ever lay eyes on it but
for horror purists lakebottom is
definitely worth tracking down the void
Jeremy Gillespie and Stephen Coe stansky
first teamed up to write and direct the
2011 horror comedy Father's Day a neo
grindhouse tribute to the ultra violent
exploitation film genre that hit its
peak in the 70s their 2017 follow up the
void uses the same genre specific cues
as that film only this time to pay
tribute to cult eighties body horror the
void is messy weird and a ton of fun it
focuses on a police officer played by
Aaron Poole who finds himself trapped at
a hospital when mysterious hooded
figures surround the building but while
staying inside seems safe he soon finds
that the greatest terror is living in
the bowels of the hospital itself it's
disgusting like Carrie levels of blood
like very gross house on Willow Street
admittedly one of the weaker entries on
this list house on Willow Street may
fall a bit short of the mark and pacing
but the premise and visual design more
than make up for its flaws the film is
about two crooks who kidnap a young
woman in the hopes of getting a ransom
from her rich father little did they
know their victim is possessed and soon
she begins to turn the tables on her
kidnappers house on Willow Street
doesn't do much to defies genre
conventions but it serves very well as a
bloody fun horror romp for a lazy
evening the dark tapes at this point
we've had our fill of anthology films
that fad arguably kicked off with 2012's
VHS I'm sure there's a reasonable
explanation since then we've had the
ABCs of death
a Christmas horror story holidays and
tales of Halloween to name a few
so when an anthology film comes along
that not only exceeds expectations but
shatters them completely it's worth a
mention the dark tapes successfully
ratchets up the horror while avoiding
all the pitfalls that have doomed so
many other entries in this genre if you
want to be grossed out by alien monsters
and scared senseless by paranormal
visitors the dark tapes is the perfect
choice and while we're on the subject of
anthologies 2017 s X X as another
quality entry in this genre and unlike
the dark tapes that ones available on
Netflix whoa for some truths thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]